hello chess fans
it's me nick risco your instructor for
tonight welcome
to chess openings explained man we just
cannot
get a break with these stream issues huh
all right well i do appreciate everyone
in the chat showing up
making sure that we're still going live
thanks for sticking around
uh i see paulo in the chat dr clash
jonathan
france is in the chat welcome
everybody tonight is chess openings
explained and tonight's opening
is the trigoran defense and this is
gonna be like a part one
of a part or i guess two or three part
series here
and tonight we're going to be focusing
on an early sea takes d5
so in exchange trigoran and for those of
you who don't know what i'm talking
about
and it's okay that is what i'm here for
we're gonna get
right into it let's go keeping in theme
with uh looking over some more d4
openings
uh that if we bring this sugar in with
d4
and d5 and black's idea is stopping
white from playing e4 right away
and keeping nice control in the center
and here white's most popular move
is c4 and this position here is the
queen's gambit
very popular position many of other
videos
on our youtube channel featuring this
position including last week's tarte
tower defense
but we're not talking about the queen's
gambit here we're not going to be
talking about the slav we're not going
to be talking about
antarctica we're going to be talking
about the trigorin defense this is
knight c6
this is the trigorin defense a
rather unpopular move again there are
more popular moves with
uh e6 the queen's gambit declined
there's takes which is the queen's
gambit accepted
and there's c6 the slav but here we go
knight takes or not knight takes knight
c6 the trigoran now here
black needs to focus on playing actively
with his pieces and use his initiative
well bishops and pawn structures are not
going to matter as much for the black
side here the initiative in time
is critical now what is some of the
methodology behind this move it looks
rather strange
again in d4 openings we're rather used
to seeing the c
pawn push before the knight move
so why would someone play knight to c6
well at a beginner level or scholastic
tournament you might see a lot of
amateur players play knight c6
simply because their coach told them put
a pawn in the center
and get your pieces off the back row for
sure
but uh at the higher level they don't
play it
just so they can develop a piece at a
higher level knight to c6 can be used
as a surprise weapon with it not being a
popular move
there's less theory on the trigorin and
what's better if you're playing the
queen's gambit declined a whole
tournament
the night before your opponent is
prepping against you queen's gambit
declined
and then on tournament day you play
knight c6 all his prep out the window
okay so again black should be focusing
on active piece play
uh pawn structures aren't the biggest
thing in the world
and tonight we're going to be looking at
c takes d
five an early capture uh in exchange
trigoran defense now here black really
only has one move to maintain
material equality queen takes d5
after queen takes d5 an appealing move
at first maybe knight to c3 but this
simply hangs upon after queen takes
d4 and black stands better simply
because of the material
so white should not play knight to c3
and black should not be scared
to see this move from white one thing
that uh
white may fall into kind of a mental
trap here is they really want to make
this knight c3 move work
so they defend with the knight and
unfortunately this doesn't quite work
out
as black has the move e5 striking at the
center
and now after knight to c3 there's
bishop to b4
pinning the knight and now your attack
on the queen
is not really there so here it makes
sense to play bishop d2
try and keep this attack working but you
see a trade
you see bishop takes pawn takes is also
playable
but hereafter bishop takes e4 hitting
the knight and after
knight to e5 or here black has
knight g to e7 with a completely fine
position white has not accomplished
anything major out of the opening other
than get a couple pieces out
um again completely equal here
so knight f3 should not be what white is
trying to play here
instead we're going to recommend e3
where yeah you block in your dark square
bishop but you have a rather
nice plan of developing it in the future
uh we'll see that in a couple moves here
so e3
what does black do
well here a very nice move and almost
mandatory
is e5 black needs to play this move in
order to maintain a challenge in the
center here
otherwise if you don't play it white is
going to have a very nice center without
much counter play from black
so not going to be too
pleasant you do need to fight uh for
equality still so e5
challenging the center and now what does
white do
white goes for this knight to c3 idea
and again black can just play a bishop
to b4 and be fine
but i do want to point out that queen d8
is
a pretty big mistake here not materially
but because of uh the space space is
going to be a big problem for black if
he's not careful
we see pawn to d5 attacking the knight
and now whether the knight goes to b8
or e7 this pawn on e3 pushes to e4
and here again we see this nice big
center for white
that can't really be challenged by black
okay so just pointing out queen d8 is a
mistake
black should play bishop to b4
after bishop to b4 there are two moves
that white can play
um the main move being bishop d2 but
first we're going to look at
pawn to a3 and the point here
is kind of i guess force black
to make this concession of giving up the
bishop pair this is going to be one of
the big advantages white has
uh here black does have to take if they
do not take
and go bishop a5 there's this move pawn
to b4
and black is dead lost the queen is
under attack
your bishop is under attack there's no
way to save both
there's nothing you can do here you
can't even try
sacrificing a piece because after a
takes b4
and let's say knight takes pawn well not
only is the knight
or sorry the queen hanging um if you try
this idea with
the moves reversed you don't need to
just take the queen
you can still take and then queen a4
is also playable and this is a nice fork
on black's pieces so black's position
just completely
falls apart after bishop to a5 so they
do have to take
this does come with check and white's
only move to maintain
material equality is pawn takes
let's talk a bit about this position
here after pawn takes
um bouchon i'm just saying this this is
not pre-recorded
i'm just putting that on the record uh
if you do have questions
feel free to put them in the chat i'll
answer but let's talk about this
position real quick after the b pawn
takes on c3
white is behind in development that is a
fact
black has the knight developed on c6 and
the queen on d5
uh white's pieces are all on the back
row so what is the compensation for this
why is white okay
being completely behind in development
like this
well they do have the bishop pair which
in this is not a closed position there's
still tension
and it can open up at any time so in
this you know semi
closed i don't know if it's on my
clothes or open um
one of those i think it's semi-closed
but the bishop pair is going to be good
if this position can open up
white also has the better structure with
these center pawns
so here with these center pawns are
pretty good
that's going to help white and black is
also going to be slow to attack it a
really nice attacking move black has in
most lines is
c7 to c5 but here cannot happen because
it's blocked by the knight on c6
we are not going to be looking at this
from black's perspective because
i just do all my lectures with white's
perspective
you can make the moves on the board if
you want to see it from black's
perspective
but because i'm not teaching you guys
how to play the openings as both sides
this is more of an opening survey
i think it's more proper to see it from
white's point of view
okay so after be take c3 uh we do have
the advantages for white now what about
black why would black go in this if
white has these
uh advantages uh well black does have
ways to seek
complications mainly by first this
tension in the center
but also active piece play if black can
keep developing his pieces on every move
and stopping lights counter play black
should have
uh some pretty nice initiative just
because the pieces
are developed off of the back row so
many moves here
are possible for black moves like knight
a5
there's e takes d4 queen d6
is a move just developing the knight to
e7
but after the years and years of this
opening being played
knight f6 has proven to be the most
reliable
now white does have a couple tempo
gaining moves here
c4 queen d6 and d5
and now knight e7 and this kind of looks
like that position where
black brought the queen back to d8 and
white has this big center
but there's a rather important
difference here
mainly that in this line with queen to
d8 after d5
97 e4 you have this dark square bishop
on the board
and it's going to be very hard to
develop this bishop unless you do
something like
g6 and fianchetto even then it doesn't
look too great because it's stuck behind
your own pawn
so one of the benefits for black here
with um going bishop to b4 and trading
off this dark square bishop
is that now after you know
white uh sorry i lost my move here not
bishop d2
um you want to go a3 um now after they
trade off this bishop
whenever white expands their center you
no longer have this dark square bishop
that's going to be stuck behind your
other pieces
your development is not going to suffer
uh
from this maneuver after knight to e7
we do see the move a4 from white
and at first this may not make a lot of
sense because
uh we're talking about developing our
pieces here
but that's actually what a4 is all about
the entire idea of a4 is to open up the
a3 square for your bishop
and get a tempo on the queen this is
another reason why this knight goes to
e7
imagine if the knight went to b8 and
then we see pawn to a4
and black castled this would be very bad
for black because now bishop a3 is a
skewer
and the only way to stop the skewer is
c5
and here white can win a pawn and get a
very comfortable game
after d takes c6 you trade the queens
so now here white's rook gets a nice
open file
and now black cannot simply take with
the knight this looks very attractive
but this hangs in exchange so you're
going to be down material here
rather black needs to give up another
pawn they play rookie 8 and they're
going to lose this b7
pawn and black takes back and here white
is up this past pawn on the c file
so this is not how black should play
this is why the knight goes to e7 that
way after a4
uh they get the chance to play c6 create
some complications and now after bishop
a3
uh they can just move the queen to c7 uh
there's no problems with like
castling and bishop a3 and then the rook
exchange hanging uh but here you do need
to play something like queen d8 which is
a little passive
uh just to make sure the knight is still
defended and you're not blocking your
bishop
so that's why i'm going to recommend c6
for black rather than castles
is you create these complications a bit
earlier
so after c6 bishop a3 queen c7 this is
about where the theory runs out
and computers seem to really like knight
f3 and this
fits in with what white is trying to do
white is just trying to
develop their pieces finish that
development uh solidify the center and
reach an end game
black's just trying to get active piece
play right away so
i think here the line is a slightly
better for whites but there's still some
good chances if they don't know what
they're doing
um the bishop on b7 seems like it would
force
pawn to f3 let's take a look at this
um no you don't need to play pawn to f3
here so you're trying i guess you're
trying to find compensation for this
lost pawn but
pawn f3 is not forced you can just play
knight f3
uh and this is no problem because if
they take
you're more than happy to take back
engines already saying this is plus
three and a half and the way it's
getting that evaluation
is because of moves like f4 and bishop
g2
looking at the rook you're also looking
at rook g1 that's looking at the king
all of white's pieces are now starting
to have some very nice
attacking avenues so
uh knight f3 is going to be completely
fine black does not want to make this
trade
instead they should develop their
knights and now after something like
uh bishop e2 is a little passive um
i think engine's saying like c5 or
knight d2 but
uh for simplicity's sake bishop e2 and
then castle's short and white has no
problems
so
uh i guess someone else is also saying
not d6 for white apparently forking
because queen a5
what are we talking about
um i am unsure of what line
that is so if you can find the line uh
put it in the chat and we'll we'll
revisit it but i i can't figure out what
line that is
we'll see if we get a response in chat
otherwise i'm going to move on to
our our main move here
[Music]
uh they're saying after c6
uh
oh yes very nice very nice point uh
patrick
patrick saying here in this position
white needs to avoid playing pawn to d6
this looks like a fork but black can
simply get out of it with check
and now after something like queen d2
queen takes d2 king d2
and knight to f5 this pawn is starting
to look
a little suspicious being so far up the
board
it's not going to benefit white just to
shove the pawn all the way up
uh it does make a bit more sense to play
moves like knight f3 continue your
development
um and let these pawns sit there's no
like worry of
captures ruining the structure because
you can always support with pawn to e4
and it's supported by the queen getting
ready to run down
so don't don't get too uh too anxious
and play d6 you can be patient here
but very nice point thank you for
bringing it up patrick
okay so those are the a3 lines for white
which
typically seem to work out well
um but the main move that's played is
bishop
to d2 and i think this is a pretty
interesting move because it tries to get
around
the fact that black is pinning the
knight so i can continue with this
attack on d5
here you have to stop the attack on the
queen so you take on c3
and now you have a choice um you can
take with the pawn
or the bishop uh i think we're going to
look
at bishop takes first
and here i do have a a lot of notes on
this position after
bishop takes um
there are a couple arguments for which
piece you should take back with the
bishop
or the pawn and i think the main
argument against taking with the bishop
is that this move is a little too slow
to justify the activity white needs to
make use of their bishop pair
i guess another way to say that is
they're playing too slow that the
advantage of the bishop pair isn't going
to be as great
as it would be if they took with the
pawn and can build up initiative
hopefully i got that point across
um so okay bishop takes c3
what should um black do well they take
on d4 with
their pawn otherwise you do have this
extra attacker with the bishop on c3
so makes a lot of sense to take
and now white should avoid taking back
right away uh if they end up taking back
right away
knight f6 and black is going to get
their development and put a rook on e8
before white and castle
which can create some problems on the
file
so rather than open it up white makes
notes
of the fact that the black queen is
hanging nothing's defending it
so rather than take back they do let it
sit
and the move i recommend here is knight
to e2
again just taking advantage of the fact
that this is a pin
knight f3 has the same ideas
but the problem with knight f3 is it
runs into bishop g4 and you get this pin
which can be a little annoying after
like bishop to e2 and now black just
castles queen side
so this is all just uh helping
black develop in time
so we get knight to e2 that way this pin
isn't any problem if they do end up
playing bishop to g4
uh f3 does come with tempo so you're
going to get that back and now after
bishop d7
now you can take on d4 with the knight
and this is a fine position for white
you do have your space you're starting
to develop your pieces
bishop d3 is coming castle's short
you're gonna have fine development
so rather than bishop to g4 after knight
f3
black does have a couple other tries
here uh
i guess one of the main ones uh being
knight g to e7
um this i i think used to be one of the
main moves but people left it behind
because it's not as ambitious
as something like knight to f6
um this can lead to a bit of a painful
position
after knight takes d4 knight takes d4
queen takes you see a queen trade
and here white with the bishop pair in
this open position
should be the one who is better um
generally speaking it's i'm not saying
it's a guaranteed win for white but i'm
going to take the bishop pair
any day of the week
i do want to revisit bishop g4 because
it appears there is a line
that i missed um is after f3
they don't have to go to d7 there's
actually a crazy piece of sacrifice
here with bishop takes f3
um so here
i guess people have said that this uh
when i say people i mean the grand
masters who
have done analysis on this these lines
um
they say that this is like not
theoretically sound but definitely
worth a shot but the problem is that
white has just had
really good results here in actual games
so
let's take a look at the position you
can get from here you get
gf3 queen f3 and now it's attacking the
rook
so this is the point of sacrificing the
piece in the first play
now bishop to d4 now you can get knight
to d4 and queen takes
and then you take the rook on h1 after
taking on
h1 there is queen takes g7 getting this
rook in the corner here
and now black castle's queen side the
only way to restore
material equality is to take on h8 and
now
black's queen will take on h2
now here uh white is down a couple pawns
for the bishop and this bishop is not
developed
so this is something that uh black can
try and take advantage of
uh but here after queen to g7 queen h4
and queen g3 black has not seen great
results
followed by queen b4 and king f2
a couple more moves just to show how the
games have continued
um queen takes b2 rook c1
and rook d6 and uh all the engine nuts
i've tried this with have just given an
advantage to white
simply because they have a bishop
instead of a couple pawns
and it's also going to be hard for black
to get these pawns rolling
but i did want to make sure i included
that
that if you see your opponent play
bishop to g4
there is this piece sacrifice that can
be rather dangerous if you don't find
the best moves
okay other than bishop g4 and knight g
to e7
knight f6 in general it seems knight f6
is going to be the move black wants to
play
rather than putting the knight on any
other square
and here in this line the reason that
black goes for this is because white
is actually going to struggle being
behind in development here
you take on d4 with the knight and black
now castles
you don't need to trade on d4 just yet
you can let it sit and if white takes
you can take back with the queen
and not risk ruining your structure
now the main move for white here is
bishop to e2
and some of you guys might be wondering
what happens if the queen takes
g2 there's actually a little trap here
after queen takes g2
with bishop to f3 the bishop protects
the rook so the queen has to
move to a safe square queen g6
and now after knight takes and pawn
takes
rather than take this pawn right away
with your bishop because it's going to
sit there for a while
there's queen to d4 just developing the
queen
and there's a very very fast plan here
for white
to castle queen side and then put a rook
on g1
and uh this there has been a couple
games here i don't have the name of a
game but
um one easy way for them to lose
is queen f5 looking like you're hitting
the bishop
but white just has this amazing
beautiful attack after bishop takes c6
and rook b8
of going rook g1 and now king
h8 to make sure that this knight is
still protected because if you don't go
this pin the pawn s or sorry the pawn
just isn't actually
defending uh you're going to lose a
piece after white takes twice so king h8
and now castle's queen side and there's
nothing that can be done against the
threat of
taking on g7 and
let's say okay black makes some random
move okay rook g7
and now if king g7 there's rook g1
king goes back now queen takes f6
this is a mate with a queen sack or not
sack you're trading queens
but like that's a thematic idea here
with trying to capture on g7
so here after castles there's nothing
that can be done against it
so rather than play queen f5 blacks only
move
uh okay they can play bishop g4 but the
only move that's been tried other than
that
is bishop to b7 and again the same idea
still applies castle queenside and
trying to attack
on the king side avoiding a queen trade
to keep extra firepower
and this is how these games have gone
and white gets a slight edge
mainly because these doubled pawns are
not friendly and you have this bishop in
a
rather open position
so that is what can happen
if black takes this pawn on g2
uh they should not take on g2 and rather
play knight to e4
and the point of knight to e4 is you're
wanting to get rid of one of white's
bishops
like this bishop on c3 so
white castles making sure they're
keeping up in development
takes takes and knight e5
uh and this can still be
played on a rather equal position
um one of the stronger games i could
find here was the game jana versus
mela denovik in 2003 between a
25 and 2600.
and this is where that game led to it
ended in a draw
so that's what uh black and white
can be looking forward to if the bishop
takes
now again a lot of those positions do
lead to equal
positions and some would say it's not
that ambitious
so those people take with the pawn
and this will go into our last few lines
here
uh there's two moves that are playable
here
uh knight f6 is the main move making
sure you're still
leading in development and there's also
queen to d6
trying to avoid uh any c4 push coming
with tempo
so you do avoid this push but this does
slow down your play that's the trade-off
and now after bishop d3 historically
white has performed
very well in this line um after you know
knight g the e7
or i think f5 has also been played here
and b6 is also a move but white has
performed very well in this line so
people tend to
avoid queen to d6 and just play knight
to
f6
we do have a question in the chat here
in general is the pawn structure of the
exchange beneficial
for black um
beneficial probably i think is a little
bit strong of a word but it does lend
its hand to black and
in the like the early stages of the game
because black does get so far ahead in
development
um so white does have other alternatives
in the beginning keeping it closed
that way they don't get run over in
development but uh i do want to show
these
moves because black may have only
studied the closed positions and not the
early trades
so it could be beneficial for black in
terms of development but i think in
the long run most of these lines turn
out to be okay for white
okay um knight f6 here
and after knight f6 uh there's a very
interesting move that i want to bring to
light
excuse me is pawn to f3
sorry about that pawn to f3
uh what is the idea well mainly you're
stopping knight to e4
or pawn to e4 gaining space
because you're putting more control on
the square
um the other move you can look at is c4
but the problem here is white is kind of
fighting before all of his pieces are
developed so the queen d65 knight v8
um we've seen these but like okay the
bishop's gone
black's gonna castle next and you don't
have pieces developed to follow up with
an attack
so that's why we're looking at f3
and after f3 there are a couple moves
here
um and i guess
one is queen d6 again avoiding the pawn
pushes that come with tempo
but um the problem is like white still
gets a fine position
as if black ended up playing queen d6
here
is that after knight f6 f3 and queen d6
you just go bishop d3 castles in 92
and white is suddenly caught up in
development
and has space so queen d6
not fantastic for black instead there is
like
castle's king side and then white does
need to be careful about pushing in the
center
too early e4 is still playable they just
need to be cautious
um making sure they have proper support
for the center so
queen b6 here sorry d6 and now
bishop e3 giz white a really nice center
otherwise knight e2 has been played
before
in the game veljavsky versus yermalinsky
both
uh almost uh i guess both over 26.50
played in 1998 in madrid
and this is kind of how that game
continued
ended up with black winning the game
but white does have better options again
i think bishop e3 is fine
keeping an ideal center for white
so there is castling queen d6 isn't the
best
but one of the better moves for black
here is pawn e4
this kind of seems a little
counter-intuitive because it's kind of
what f3 was trying to avoid in the first
place was saying um you know
i guess white's trying to play e4
instead black's gonna play e4
themselves uh and here white can face
some unusual problems
which is why i've recommended this as
blacks try just because the problems
white faces are
different than what white will normally
face here
is that white can be a little
constrained they don't get to expand in
the center how they want to
um so yeah
that's why i recommend this and the way
that this continues
is uh pawn to c4 hitting the queen with
tempo
the queen cannot move laterally so you
see queen d6
after queen d6 instead of this like d5
push we've been seeing the problem with
d5 is that now this pawn is moved
the pawn on e5 has moved so now knight
e5
is playable putting pressure on c4
so uh this is one of the problems with
d5
instead white has this move queen b1
putting pressure on the pawn bishop f5
is supporting the pawn and now pawn f4
you can't allow black to take on
f3 with this bishop here if they get a
chance to
protect it like queen d7 and then takes
uh this is a slow line but just uh
illustrative purposes
so here we have f4 now black does have
the opportunity to castle
and the way white will finish their
development is by bringing the knight to
e2
now you bring the knight before the
bishop it seems a little strange that
you
you block off the bishop but this knight
is uh able to come to c3
or g3 and then you put the bishop on e2
but if you put the bishop on e2 you no
longer can develop the knight to its
ideal square so
it's a timing thing you develop the
knight first
knight goes to g3 hitting the bishop
bishop goes back
and now you see bishop to e2 and black
can just
bring the rooks to the center bishop to
c3 supporting
97 transferring the rip to the king side
um with a little pawn sacrifice here
queen takes b7 knight c6 and followed by
rook to b8
says it looks like white can't really
castle i
don't agree just because you play f4
doesn't mean you can't castle
king's side uh it can definitely look
scary
if like you don't have this pawn on d4
because then e3 is a weakness but with
black's dark square bishop being gone
the queen kind of stuck behind all these
pawns
it's not a real problem and in fact um
in this main line here sorry knight c6
is not a good move
uh here actually uh you go bishop g4
but uh just an illustrative line to show
where you know this can go
um you bring the queen to safety and
you can castle later you don't need to
try and force castling too
soon but uh yeah and now you can
use the rook behind the f pawn to push
on the king's side so um
yeah uh knight c6 earlier was not a good
move
this is just uh taken from the great
game rajab versus antal from budapest
2000 uh so that was just a little
illustration of how it could go again 97
probably not the best move bishop g4 is
uh much better
but yeah guys that is basically
a survey of the exchange trigorin i'll
open up the last few minutes here for
any other questions
uh bless p does black ever have ideas of
playing c5
to break the d4 center so
this is one of the things i talked about
in the very beginning um
i think all the way back
here on e3
and then to do after bishop
d2 really after bishop b4 here in this
position here um you can start to see
some of the problems
um yeah yeah so i did say that
uh if the d-pawn isn't there it might
look scary
um but the problem with the trigorin is
that with this knight on c6
black almost never has the time to move
the knight and then
play c5 it's just too slow
if black is trying to go for this idea
of playing c5 they shouldn't be playing
the trigoran
uh from what it seems like in
the the games i've looked at black isn't
going to be trying to
to go for pawn structure stuff like that
it's all going to be about developing
the pieces
as fast as possible and trying to attack
rather than
a meticulous breakdown of white
central pawn structure
because i don't i can't like find a time
when black actually has the time to do
this
um the trade is necessary because the
queen is attacked
f3 is fighting to play e4
and because both of these can come with
tempo white or sorry black tries to
fight back themselves c4
they go back queen b1
i guess you can try and say 97 here but
this must be wrong for some reason
just uh takes on e4 actually
so you like have to take on f3 knight
takes on f3
uh there's just like no time when knight
e7 is good
to play c5 so yeah it just doesn't work
out
what ideas does black have at the end of
the main line that i just showed
okay so like bishop e2 at the end
here um black's gonna expand on the
queen side
and try and make some progress over here
you have more pawns on the queen side
it's opposite the side you castled so
this is gonna be where you're trying to
focus
try and create a past pawn maybe focus
on you know
white weak a pawn for sure maybe the c
pawn is a weakness
so hopefully hopefully that gives you a
bit of a plan
um as of what to do in this position
uh sandro shock is asking
if you play d4 and then two knight c3
are you playing the trigorian a tempo up
yeah this is known as the queen's pawn
game
trigorin variation um
but i am i'm not confident in saying the
plans are the same because sometimes
reversed colors the plans are much
different such as
the the english and the sicilian uh
totally different plans
for both openings but if you're
interested in seeing this
we can definitely cover this in a future
future lecture
okay uh bishop a7 in the chat
is asking is f takes e4 possible
to open up the file for the rook after
castling
so let's go through this main line here
after white
castles well okay the problem is like
you don't really want to take here
because the bishop takes and your queen
gets tempo'd
like if you take even knight takes can
be pretty potent
trying to get the bishop pair and this
is one of the things you really want to
avoid as white this bishop pair is
actually where you're getting a lot of
your compensation
for the lack in development so uh the
pawn never
sits on f3 that long you do have to
close up the position
that way there's no huge threats here
um but eventually you'll notice after
developing like
knight g3 kicks the bishop away so that
way after you do
castle there can be plans
of running this pawn up the board
sometimes all the way up to f6 if this
knight is kicked
so while you can't just capture and open
up the file
you can now start thinking of using this
pawn as a batarang ram
to tear apart uh black's king side
structure here
all right uh do you have any last minute
questions we'll give it
30 seconds and then we're gonna move on
to
our twitch stream uh yeah over on twitch
we are still continuing the winner's
circle but
we did finish zurich 1953 so
tonight with the us chess champs i think
it's a little inappropriate to start a
new series
but luckily i found a historical
tournament that is rather short
and we can hopefully get through all the
games tonight we're going to be covering
the syncfield cup 2013
so i don't see any new questions coming
in we're going to wrap it up on youtube
thanks for coming for part one of the
trigorin
um i think the next openings explained
lecture is going to be
after the us championships so thanks
everyone for coming out i will see you
right over on twitch